congratulations by finding this video  you have survived into the second round  of the program please go to the space  weather prediction center website at  swpc.noaa.gov and copy the solar wind  speed along with the magnetic field and  paste both into the comments below under  no circumstances should your comment  include the radio flux doing so or  providing any other information besides  the solar wind speed and magnetic field  will lead to immediate termination from  the program if you are confused or have  no memory of entering into the program  be advised there is no mistake you are a  member of the program knowledge of your  membership or methods of survival are  considered non-essential please listen  to the following audio briefing and  await further instructions  thank you you may now move on